kylie jenner hits a Fashion Week in a  skin tight and see-through jumpsuit the  reality star posted at this pic to  Instagram Wednesday showing of all her  assets in the Lacey one piece she paired  the outfit with some gold bangles and  pointy gold heels then rocked the look  and a Starbucks cup front row at the V  files fashion show though she covered up  a little by clutching onto a fluffy coat  Kylie has been all over New York Fashion  Week she and sister Kendall even debuted  their own collection there Ichi was at  the launch did Kanye give you guys any  good advice and launching the line cuz  obviously that's something he's done  very very well yeah he is so creative  but he didn't give us any advice I don't  think we really wanted anyone else's  opinion other than ours and we wanted to  be really organic  really representing